I'm Tom Segura and I'm here to answer
the internet again let's see is sex with
conjoined twins of Theresa it's actually
it's a deep question
what's Wild is when they have these
stories they're like there's one of them
is getting married to this guy or like
one of them's dating there was one
recently one was celibate yeah I don't
have sex just in the room with my
sisters yeah yeah I don't vote so that's
my question is if it's one [__] and two
brains versus gun count it's got to be
two yeah it does yeah yeah I mean it's
it's uh it's gross
like one of the grossest things you
could do would you if they were good
looking good joint twins did you do they
never are yeah yeah they're always like
every time they go like we could yeah
you know they're like my question is
always the guy dating them he's [__]
out of his mind when you come back to
like your boys and you're like yo I got
a girlfriend and it's like who is it and
it's like it's these two people and
they're connecting heads don't you think
he has the uh the complex of like I'm
trying to like take care of somebody
like somebody needs to help a thousand
percent and you're also like kind of
raping the other girl
would you rather everyone be naked all
the time or close naked all the time
really yeah because well here's family
members women fat people because I look
like a peek I would like I'd like to
know what I'm dealing with I'd like to
know who you are I think it would be a
pretty com imagine I mean look all the
time I guess is the part that I yeah
because obviously you get a peek and
then you see them all the time [__]
naked bird all the time nah
which NFL team would win all white
players or All Blacks what do we do
that to be fair that question's from
like 2010 when it was like we had all
the quarterbacks and no announcing
pretty much okay every year whenever
those questions asked it's Alaska okay
you know the real problem is
quarterbacks we're just we're gonna get
toasted in secondary everything if it's
not Jesus
would you rather watch only softcore
porn for the rest of your life or only
Minor League Sports for the rest of your
life
foreign
can you still go to your Barber if he is
very racist a hundred percent I guess
why you go to the barber I want to hear
some wild out of pocket [__] set and I'm
going to encourage I'll be like I know
oh yeah [__] them yeah anytime you get
an Uber and the guy's like these [__]
Arabs you're like yeah I know what do
you think you just kind of you want to
hear me yeah yeah
I know right passports would you rather
spend the rest of your life in a country
music video or a rap music video I mean
I think there's like what kind of Life
do you want to realize the question bro
yeah it's like uh personally I think the
rap music video is gonna be like it's
not gonna be as peaceful as the question
get a lot of downtime but I like big fat
asses and I like bass you know my
question is I'm with you like we're both
the same with music but I almost feel
like I would just fit in better at a
country music without question right so
it's like I would rather be with you
guys but they're going to look at me
like who the [__] is this guy also if
we're in the world in the park if we're
in the rap music video we're either the
cop or the yeah
you're going away
that's that's what her cast has that's
always it yeah like those old Dre videos
whereas the white guy here's how every
every music video from the late 80s and
early 90s ended okay it was always the
rapper would always go
and then just walk away like because he
was done telling the judge
and they judge is like so true would you
rather have a good [__] from your
grandmother or a bad hand job from your
grandmother oh Jesus uh honestly good
honestly yeah well it's traumatizing
enough no matter well but it I it's uh
it'll be over quicker if it's good it is
but it's also like if Grandma's like
spitting on it and [__] you know it's
like whoa I know but like
like this [__] horrible thing
happened what happened I came so hard in
my grandmother's hands it's like
it's it's I just think it's it's
traumatic either way if it's traumatic
and terrible I think that's worse would
you rather watch your dad [__] 100 year
old man or watch your mother kills him
100 I'd watch my mother kill someone I
don't think anybody in the history of
the question has ever answered their dad
yeah it's like wanting to watch him [__]
100 year old first of all he kills that
man that's true so either way it's a
murder no it's the old man if it was
like watch your dad [__] a dude I'm like
I don't know
I'd love to watch my mother kill someone
and think that she's alone and just have
her turn around and be like it's me
that was [__] crazy like I would love
and have her be like
I didn't know like I [__] that was
nuts you cut him open like that's so
crazy these cuts are awesome
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out